[Musica]
dare respiro la storia ma perché la
storia ha bisogno di respiro gli
studenti la pensano così e me lo dicono
sempre spesso cioè prof
cioè io la storia proprio non
c'è la serie noiosa non gli è mai
piaciuta e pesante quanti qui sarebbero
d'accordo con i miei studenti o
conoscono qualcuno che lo sarebbe guardo
con marco quali meno giovani figli sulle
mani ma davvero
così pochi
ma vediamo se riesco a darvi una
prospettiva diversa in 8 minuti
vi racconto una storia
spini express per gli amici spicek a 18
anni e il primo settembre del 1939 viene
spedito dalla scuola militare che non ha
ancora terminato sul fronte occidentale
del suo paese la polonia perché in
quella data hitler ha deciso di
scatenare la seconda guerra mondiale
anche se non ci piace la storia quelli
che ho visto alzarle mano forse lo
sappiamo che il fronte cede subito è la
guerra lampo
dice che viene fatto prigioniero ma
riesce a scappare ai nazisti a quel
punto si rende conto che non ha molti
posti dove nascondersi perché dall'altra
parte da oriente l'armata rossa
sovietica iniziato una contro invasione
in pratica germania e russe si sono
spartiti la polonia
allora lui decide di fare una cosa
particolare decide di attraversare il
confine con l'ungheria montagne vuol
dire marciare a piedi giorno e notte
ininterrottamente
tre giorni e tre notti nella neve per
arrivare in territorio neutrale riunirsi
con altri soldati che sono riusciti a
sfuggire ai tedeschi soldati di quell
esercito polacco esploso si ritrovano
dall'altra parte decidono di dare vita
un'unità militare lo chiamano l'esercito
per la liberazione della polonia che
combatterà con le forze alleate
praticamente su tutti i fronti della
seconda guerra mondiale e proviamo a
immaginarselo questo ragazzo di 19 anni
speech ma proviamo a immaginarci noi
come eravamo quando avevamo 19 anni o
nostro figlio diciannovenne un nostro
nipote
19enne proviamo a immaginarselo che
decide di combattere una guerra che
sembra finita ma non è finita che decide
di combattere per la libertà di una
patria che non vedrà neppure più non
toccherà neppure più per anni lanciato
in questa crogiuolo ardente che il mondo
impazzito della seconda guerra mondiale
proviamo a immaginarci prima
immaginarselo combattere nell assedio
africano del porto di tobruk 50 gradi
all'ombra per settimane o sotto le
pendici del nostro montecassino e qui
chiunque abbia visto il cimitero polacco
di montecassino almeno una volta sa di
che cosa sto parlando una distesa
infinita tragica commovente di croci
migliaia allora proviamo a immaginarlo
questo ragazzo vi rendete conto che cosa
fa 19 anni proviamo a immaginarci la sua
storia e perché io non ho il tempo di
raccontarvela tutta ne ho fatto uno
storytelling e storytelling e il nome
che io do al modo che mi sono inventato
per provare a dare respiro alla storia
cos'è uno storytelling beh una cosa
fatta da tante da tanti pezzi o ve ne
racconto 3 che mi sembrano essenziali
uno lo avete già sentito
avrei potuto raccontarvi la storia
dell'esercito della polonia libera
inserendolo nella grande storia quella
con la s maiuscola avrei potuto darvi il
numero dei soldati le cifre sulle
vittime le date delle battaglie
combattute ma ho preferito proporvi una
storia paul s minuscola storico la s
minuscola sono quelle delle persone vive
concrete le persone che attraversano la
storia e sono attraversate dalla storia
sangue che pulsa nelle vene sentimenti
come ha detto un grande maestro marc
bloch
odore di carne umana
il secondo elemento è sostituire la
fredda e distaccata spiegazione con una
narrazione che usi tutti i materiali
disponibili io nei miei che storytelling
uso
canzoni e film e poesie romanzi musica
suonata dal vivo disegni fatti dal vivo
qualunque elemento possa permettere di
suscitare le emozioni che ci consentono
di
immedesimarsi immedesimarci in un tempo
passato che inevitabilmente ci sfugge
continuamente dalle dita ogni istante
che passa e poi il terzo elemento
appunto le emozioni come collante tra le
informazioni che già abbiamo e che
magari invece aumentiamo ne conosciamo
di nuovo attraverso un misto ritelli in
un racconto come passatemi il termine un
ricostituente per la nostra memoria ci
soccorrono le neuroscienze in questo
attenzione io ho in mente degli studi di
john medina ma ce ne sono anche altre
che parlano di its
stimoli ad alto contenuto emotivo
detto più semplicemente le emozioni
suscitano attenzione e i fatti che prova
con emozione vengono ricordati molto
meglio
ecco perché serve usare materiali di
ogni genere
come faccio a spiegare
non funziona così con le canzoni ad
esempio facciamo mi aiutate facciamo un
esperimento tutti insieme provate a
pensare al grande amore della vostra
vita
ma su un serio è però aiutati non è una
domanda retorica
come vedo agli sguardi preoccupati non
vi chiedo e non ho intenzione di
suscitare
imbarazzanti incidenti o pensateci pochi
secondi io sono sicuro che vi verrà
istintivo collegare una canzone una
musica lui o lei no
io io me la ricordo con la spiaggia è
quella ragazza e alla canzone
e tutte le volte che sento con la
canzone pam sono l'anno m83 dirvi la
data l'ora la luce che c'era l'odore che
si sentiva
profumo dei suoi capelli ecco gli
storytelling funzionano anche con questi
meccanismi
meccanismi nuovi
rivoluzionari per niente va da te lo
sapevano già gli antichi per i quali la
storia era fabula doveva suscitare
voluptas giù con l'itas piacere
godimento
immedesimazione divertimento perché
allora non piace perché si dice che non
ha respiro perché
perché ce l'hanno soffocata dentro molto
presto quando eravamo bambini con decine
e decine di interrogazioni in cui c'è
stato chiesto di restituire di solito a
memoria dati e date nomi di condottieri
e di battaglie che badate bene scusate
lo dico forte e chiaro non voglio essere
frainteso la razionalizzazione e la
verbalizzazione vanno benissimo sono
fondamentali non vanno buttati via ma se
mi chiedete se questo è il modo di dare
respiro alla storia se devo essere
sincero no credo di no
il problema capite da questo punto di
vista diventa diventa abbastanza
complicato è per questo che quando
qualcuno mi chiede mi dice che la storia
non gli è mai piaciuta io rispondo che
mente magari senza volerlo
inconsapevolmente ma mente perché in
quel mai piaciuta c'è una piccola grande
bugia perché lo sappiamo tutti tutti
indistintamente è che non è vero che c'è
stato un tempo in cui la storia ci
piaceva moltissimo non desideravamo
altro che racconto di un tempo in cui
noi non eravamo ancora è questo che
eravamo con passione e chiunque ha avuto
per casa un bambino un figlio un
nipotino o semplicemente chi si ricorda
ancora come era lui stesso lei stessa da
piccolo sta benissimo che andava così
com'è che andava dai
nonna nonna thai c'è ma cocco come
quella storia lì di quando i codici che
c'era la guerra in una realtà mangiare e
tu il nonno e e c'era sempre buio alla
sera perché non si poteva accendere la
luce si losca mi fa paura ma mi piace
dai racconti non so che me l'hai
raccontato un mucchio di volte racconta
melo ancora al cuore allora se non
ritorneremo come bambini avremmo perso
la nostra partita con la storia prima
ancora
prima ancora di giocarlo possiamo
ricordarci come eravamo quando la storia
ci piaceva quando ci appassiona va tutti
noi che raccontiamo voi che ascoltarle
ma più di tutto andando via da qui
proviamo a ricordarci perché altrimenti
quante occasioni
infinite di voluptas di piacere ci
perdiamo si fa storia ricordiamocelo
perché il bello farlo perché c'è una
bella differenza tra cercare di imparare
una storia senza respiro e ascoltare
storie che tolgono il respiro
solo così la storia non diventa pesante
e
riacquista tutta la sua
fantastica leggerezza grazie
[Applauso]